to Northern Israel in fact the uh the
Lebanon Israel border area and what we
just saw happen there in the last 40
minutes or so that breaking news that we
were bringing you a short time ago about
a serious escalation on the border
between uh uh Israel and Southern
Lebanon dozens of rockets fired at the
town of kirat Shimona settlement and its
surroundings well elas hanana is a
retired Lebanese General and a strategic
analyst you're joining us from Beirut
sir we appreciate the the scramble to
come up live for us at such short notice
I I we wanted to ask you for your
assessment of what we saw the pictures
of course are quite dramatic you see
cars on fire in Kat Shimona you see the
the First Responders kirat Shimona had
been mostly evacuated there are two
people lightly
injured what meaning do you ascribe to
this where how do you fit this into the
wider
picture I think that are seeing uh that
the rule of Rules of Engagement are
rapidly changing today the changes are
in intensity you know the bombardment on
both side as well as the means used the
first time we see uh uh suicide drones
used against uh uh uh command and
control for the IDF and Zine and Sh so
this is like a major change moreover the
depth of the bombardment and really
hitting the uh uh settlements like
Katona moreover in addition to this we
can see that uh you know who is really
executing all of this it's not onlyb we
are seeing you know different
Palestinian faction and you know uh
loudly they are saying they are
participating so we are seeing like
little bit of escalation maybe and this
is like analysis maybe waiting for
tomorrow for say Hass speech because
after 26 27 days of absence and with 50
Mar killed from his you know party he
has to come and say what would be the
picture after what would be the picture
after really encircling Gaza City and
maybe hitting the Gaza or or Hamas so
maybe what's gonna go for the future you
know the road map for the future I guess
so maybe it's like a preparation yeah
why hasn't Nala spoken for 27 days and
also the same question to you that I
asked our correspondent earlier is what
will you be listening for in that speech
specifically I think he's going to
really explain the Strategic choices
that are made by the access of
resistance and
why though he wanted the earlier or
prior to this to destroy all of Israel
is not really participating though he
lost like 50 uh 50 Fighters 50 Martyrs
moreover uh he wants to relate I think
that the escalation in Gaza is directly
related to the escalation in Lebanon and
moreover we are seeing more broader the
unity of the theaters between what's
from the Yemen coming from Syria from
Iraq and from Lebanon but I think that
uh he will go into uh the the most I
mean the escalation yeah he goes into
more escalation but I think so far it's
like short of War why because we are not
seeing now that the Proxes are working I
see that you know the the master like
Iran and the United States of America
directly are really conducting what's
going on on the earth on on the on the
Gaza that's interesting so you're seeing
you're seeing escalation of some sort
but something short of a full-blown War
by Hezbollah and and why is that is that
because you think Hezbollah just doesn't
have isn't incentivized to open the full
war against Israel right now what what
would be the reason uh for either going
to war or not going to war
the decision to go to war I think it's
in the Iran's hands moreover if you go
into like Iran as russal player they are
really calculating and waiting what's
going to happen in in Gaza if the
Israelis will really destroy Hamas
totally this is something different
moreover if the Israelis will not be
able to go into Gaza and really destroy
Hamas I mean Hamas wins because Hamas
wins if it didn't and Israel loses if it
didn't win so we will have the same
situation as in 2006 I mean you are
really encircling Hamas but you cannot
really destroy Hamas moreover you will
be I mean you will be immersed in this
kind of things like protracted uh
protracted conflict and you have like
internal political problem internal
strategic problem internal intelligence
problem moreover inter an internal
economic problem and uh uh uh uh Iran
will win you know for good
one you know I'm I'm going to remember
what you just said Israel loses if it
doesn't win Hamas wins if it doesn't
lose uh I'll remember that one um elas
Hanah retired Lebanese General thank you
so much again for the scramble to join
us live on such short notice we
appreciate it